ouch le grand rendez vous de ce soir la
télévision c'est sur antenne 2 que vous
le vivre et juste après ce journal
pendant plus de deux heures
nous allons vous parler du cancer et des
moyens de le guérir
ce ne sera pas une émission triste
encore moins dramatique vous ne verrez
pas de ces images traumatisantes et qui
peuplent trop souvent les émissions de
ce genre dont ce soir nous vous parlons
de la guérison
c'est le rendez-vous de l'espoir car
c'est vrai martin alarie new on peut
guérir le cancer
vous apporterez ce soir l'illustration
et les témoignages avec vos invités
bernard on peut le dire
la bataille n'est pas gagnée mais elle
est très bien engagée et pour témoigner
ce soir j'ai autour de moi dans la
préparation de cette émission
armand jammot marie laure augry monsieur
francis bouygues et deux petites filles
l'une a été le scénic et sa soeur lui a
donné sa moelle osseuse tout le monde
auto aujourd'hui est là pour dire que et
bien on ne meurt pas forcément du cancer
on se bat on peut gagner la bataille et
il faut le concours de tout le monde
pour y arriver voilà pourquoi ils sont
venus ce soir
et voilà pourquoi aussi ce soir nous
allons privilégier en direct ceux qui
sont avec nous évidemment la médecine ne
sera pas absente de ce débat vous
l'imaginez bien quand on parle de cancer
on parle de progrès on parle de
diagnostic de traitement mais tout ceci
sera fait ailleurs qu'ici ici avec nous
il y aura des êtres humains la médecine
à deux aspects l'aspect technique un
aspect humain
ce soir nous privilégions les êtres
humains le verso optimiste donc de la
maladie je crois qu'on peut dire martin
dont nous parlait tout à l'heure que en
définitive la formation fait la
différence est que souvent et bien les
traitements sont un petit peu en retard
ou plutôt son avance sur l'opinion
publique
il sait pas bien comment ça se passe oui
et la peur et l'ignorance ont très
mauvaise conseillère fait pourquoi ce
soir nous avons décidé d'une grande
soirée d'information alors vous avez à
vos côtés francis bouygues et j'aimerais
me posais une question si vous me le
permettez temps des lui un micro mais
chez bouygues
vous êtes un grand patron un chef
d'entreprise est ce que l'on ressort
différent d'une maladie comme celle dont
vous avez souffert et de différent
aujourd'hui
bernard rapp demande si vous sentez que
vous êtes différent quand on sort d'une
telle maladie bien
bien sûr un homme après onze ans de
maladie est un homme différent qui n'est
plus le même
je dirais aujourd'hui que je me sens
beaucoup plus fort qu'il ya onze ans
évidemment je n'ai plus la même force
physique bien sûr mais j'envisage la vie
d'une manière différente
j'envisage la vie souvent comme une
bataille comme une bataille que l'on
peut gagner et au cours de mes quatorze
mois de convalescence
lors de mon cancer j'ai appris à me
battre et je gagnais il est dit
l'ailière barrard que monsieur will
continue à le battre nous le savons tous
aujourd'hui
bien sûr bien écoutez vous reviendra en
détail toute façon tout à l'heure sur
les nouveaux traitements martin des
nouvelles chances qui s'offrent en
quelque sorte aux malades et voici
partagée de direct et wii puis pas de
médecin sur le plateau mais beaucoup de
médecins qui ont enregistré des messages
et filles nous soutiennent et qui vous
soutiennent